how's this for a revenge body i love to
work out and i love to just like that's
my selfish time khloe kardashian's hard
work on her back and arms clearly paid
off and she's not afraid to show off the
results sharing these before and after
pics to instagram on tuesday chloe
explained in the caption about three
months apart on monday chloe also shared
this topless photo promoting denim jeans
from the apparel company she co-founded
good american i think it's important to
surround yourself with people that you
share the same passions and working out
is one of my new obsession healthy
obsessions the new progress picks come
after new details e.t learned about
chloe's mindset a source told e.t last
week chloe has been spending time with
her sisters and family working out
eating healthy and focusing on her mind
body and soul like i'm gonna figure it
all out i promise you the source added
she is getting back on her a-game she
looks better than ever and her body is
on fire but she is not even trying to
date i'm focused on work and like taking
care of me my body and soul this follows
chloe's very public drama with ex
tristan thompson the pair are parents to
three-year-old daughter true last month
tristan revealed following a paternity
test he fathered a son with marylee
nichols prior to the revelation a
sourceful e.t at the time chloe and
tristan were planning on moving in
together he shared this public apology
on instagram writing in part quote chloe
you don't deserve this you don't deserve
the heartache and humiliation i have
caused you you don't deserve the way i
have treated you over the years the
source added chloe was quote really hurt
and saddened by tristan's actions
genuinely i cannot believe it chloe and
tristan have had an on and off romance
since 2016 which includes several
cheating allegations against the nba
star including the most recent with
marylee you know tristan and i
definitely are not perfect do you trust
him
i mean i definitely trust him as a
friend and all those things meanwhile
chloe's ex-husband lamar odom is
starting his own next chapter
what are you
are you 9 feet 10
10 feet 9. look look at that [ __ ]
[Laughter]
as the former nba star heads into the
celebrity big brother house lamar told
et he hopes to bump into a familiar face
who am i hoping is in the big brother
house well i'm hoping i'll bump into
khloe kardashian
[Music]
you